à
après ses marchés et ses centres
commerciaux israël relança culture 500
personnes étaient réunies pour écouter
le chanteur pop ivri lider à tel aviv
dans un stade de 30000 places
aujourd'hui nous sommes donc autorisés à
ouvrir notre industrie culturelle avec
des restrictions seulement les
spectacles en plein air c'est pourquoi
nous le faisons dans le stade tout le
monde ici a été vaccinée tout le monde
doit prouver qu'il n'est pas malade et
bien sûr maintenir une distance sociale
entre les couples seule condition pour
assister au concert montrer son badge
verts version israélienne du passeport
vaccinale une preuve que les spectateurs
ont bien reçu les deux doses de vaccins
nécessaires pour les participants c'est
le début d'un retour à la vie d'avant
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un moment incroyable ici
à tel aviv après un an vraiment
désespérante nous revenons à l'avion
merci pour les vaccins grâce aux vaccins
nous nous sentons un nouveau bilan nous
avons ouvert les musées
dimanche nous rouvrons les restaurants
et certaines écoles cela marque la fin
de cette période avec la plupart des
israéliens vacciner espérons que le
virus tel que nous l'avons connue est
derrière nous avec 42 % de sa population
déjà vacciné contre à peine 6 en europe
l'état hébreu a pris une longueur
d'avancé sur la vaccination
grâce en partie à son accord avec le
laboratoire pfizer
mais la fin de la pandémie en israël ce
n'est pas encore pour tout de suite
selon les données du ministère de la
santé le taux de reproduction vendredi
était encore de 1.011 malades contamine
donc toujours plus d'une personne en
israël
signe que l'épidémie ne recule pas un
quatrième confinement serait même
envisagée
nous avons quelques semaines cruciales
devant nous il est tout à fait possible
que nous observions une augmentation du
nombre des malades dans un état grave
nous devrons peut-être imposer de
nouvelles restrictions et peut-être même
un autre confinement parmi les
inquiétudes la réouverture progressive
de l'aéroport ben gourion
il doit permettre aux israéliens de
rentrer voter pour les élections
législatives du 23 mars prochain mais
présente aussi un risque d'importation
des variants britanniques ou
sud-africains l'état hébreu dénombre un
peu plus de 40000 qu'actif et près de
700 patients se trouvent en état grave
à ce jour près de six mille israéliens
sont décédées des suites de la maladie
pour 800 mille contamination ici comme
ailleurs il faudra attendre un peu avant
de chanter le retour des beaux jours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]